but keen to be here is indicated that he
will leave at about 11 20 11 10 11 15
somewhere around about there yeah
anybody else got anything else need to
drive i've got another one at 11 30. 11
30. so that means i need to be finished
by oh won't be finished sorry for 12.
allen
[Laughter]
okay look um can i move from the chair
that we take those uh we sustain those
apologies
um uh with some sense that i might try
and get done by 11 30 if we can can i
have a second to please
thank you rangi i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
those against
it's caring brilliant
are there any matters of interest uh um
on the agenda that people need to raise
um i wonder malavika just remind me i do
have a very minor one i just wanted to
clear when we get into uh public
excluded
it's not a big drama but i'll let you
know at that stage
i've had no request
for
um uh
public
at all g'day darren um so uh major late
items we have a we actually have a
couple
um uh there is an updated performance
report that has been um added to
um diligent boardwalks
so if you haven't resent now's a hang of
time to do that
um
and the other thing um is that
we will have our external auditor derek
olson with us later in the meeting
and there is an initial paper on the the
sort of outline of this year's annual
audit um derek has overnight given us an
actual plan
so
i take it patricia that has been
circulated has it yeah
all right so it's been it's been sinked
in as well great thank you very much so
that's in your books
uh as well
um
so
if you could note that please i'll move
from the chair that we um receive those
major load items don't have a second
thank you becks i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
those against
it's kerry
the second thing um the second thing i'd
like um to do
is just look at the agenda and just just
recommend one uh change and that is is
that we do have as i've said derek olson
our external order um coming
due to speak for item six and also the
first the first item after the minutes
and the extra ordinary so what i'd like
to propose is that we deal with error
roughly
in one hit
so i'd like to move item six to the last
item in in the open agenda so that we
can then deal with that issue which is
the audit plan
and then when we go into public excluded
deal with the item that is relevant to
him
that's the one change i would propose
with the agenda is any comments or
questions people like to raise on that
it's just about expediency and being
in that case i'll um i'll put that we
confirm the agenda with that amendment
um with item six moving to the end of
the open session do i have a second to
please
thank you rangi i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
those against
let's carry
right now i'm going to open my agenda
and get myself going
can i um please move then to item four
and indeed item five we'll do the item
four first obviously which is receipt of
the minutes
um we've got a couple to do obviously
the first was our last risk and
assurance committee meeting held on the
16th
of december from the chair i'll move
that we accept these a true and correct
record do i have a second to please
thank you bex is there any discussion
matters of accuracy that need to be
raised
at this point
because i want to say it looked like the
meeting i was at so um that's that's
great okay so look oh no there's no
discussion i'll put the motion then
please all those in favor please say aye
aye those against
let's carry
then of course we had a second meeting
on the 21st of december primarily in
relationship to the annual report
um
again from the chair i'll move the
leader accepted the true and correct
record thank you darren is there any
discussion uh on
this set of minutes accurate makes sense
to you
well exactly thank you okay i'll put the
motion in please all those in favor
please say aye aye those against
it's carrie thank you very much so just
to note again that we are up to item six
but i'm holding that over to the end so
if we could move to item seven
which is the health and safety report
please
uh mr chair uh gary is actually away as
a result of covert i think michael might
be happy to take the reporters read and
answer any questions
right i wonder whether even the covet
section clear was up to date given the
announcements overnight but is there
anything that you could share with that
at this stage look um to date we've been
relatively fortunate at invercargill
city we've had about 15 people off at
any one time
we've got a covered response team of
about half a dozen officers eight nine
officers working uh but we delegated
authority to russell pearson to be the
covert response manager dealing with it
a little bit like the civil defense
process uh it's been well received that
somebody from within the team is
advising the team what to do
and it's gone well
uh we've implemented the changes as
they've come about council delegated the
authority to me on tuesday night to
adjust settings at those areas where we
have introduced vaccine mandates
and i put out a need a note to
councillors last night to say that
although
the change comes in from 11 59 pm on
monday the 4th of april we will
introduce them from 11 59 pm on sunday
the third of april so we start a new
week with no armor guide no security uh
back to normal as you might put it we
will however be reassessing the risk
assessments
around uh now that a passport requires
three shots
um if we have assist
the officer as needing to be vaccinated
for the purposes of holding a role and a
swimming teacher is a good example of
that we'll be making sure that all swim
teachers have had
the third shot as well
thank you yes
um can i just uh seek some clarification
about the
council chamber
and with a masks on or masks off just
you know because it's quite nice i've
got my mask off but if i have to put it
back on
i would do so the standard mr chair is
that mask should be on unless people are
drinking
or speaking
it's remarkable
[Laughter]
it is remarkable how hydration has been
better attended to okay i'll keep
drinking mr cheers cheers
in the nature of the value of learnings
i would highlight one thing from this
report
and that is the splash palace fire alarm
and look the there was a fire alarm at
splash palace swimmers had to get out uh
the building was evacuated um it was an
inconvenience there were a number of
things we learned from that process
but more than that and and what's
referred to here is that whilst we were
fully compliant at all times with
building codes and so on we actually
went right back to the beginning to say
what caused this to come about and i
think it would be fair to say that there
was a degree of frustration felt by some
officers as we continued saying but why
but why
but actually where we've got to out of
it is a really good sense of the
learnings from it that we can apply to
other areas and it's actually something
that's really providing some clarity
about who's responsible for what which
always helps people in the performance
of their roles so really pleased with
the piece of work that's been done there
well look if i could endorse it that's
great because health and safety isn't
about meeting a minimum target it's
actually about what is relevant and good
so i noticed the
idea in the concept of
root cause analysis which makes sense
yes ross
uh two questions one is
around covert and
if you can comment on
mental any mental health issues that you
might be experiencing and i'm finding it
common and a lot of organizations the
stress that people in their families are
under
mr chair i would refer to a conversation
i had with the senior manager yesterday
where the comment was that our staff
are actually beginning to behave like
our demanding customers
i set it in the chamber in relation to
our customers and the need for security
guards that people people are on a
shorter wick than usual
and we're certainly seeing that
courtesy is the first thing to go when
people are feeling more harassed and
whether it's the need to remember your
mask and not just your keys and your
wall on your cell phone or or whether
it's
um i've got family visiting and are they
going to get out without
a positive rat test
but we're seeing
that courtesy and
shorter wicks uh the way i would
describe it best of all
it wouldn't be exclusive to this
organisation
not exclusive at all
um i think one of the difficulties of
this organisation though is that
people work for local government not
because they want to be paid the
greatest amount or because they want to
get the
fancy incentive bonuses but rather
because they want to make a difference
in their community and it's the thing
that comes through all the time and yeah
and the other thing that comes through
all the time is that they really enjoy
the people they work with they might not
like the management they might not like
the governance but they really enjoy the
people they work with
and it gets harder to think about
recovery and well-being when the people
you work with in the community you serve
are both snapping quite quickly
and there's a challenge for us as
managers about how we lead a recovery
and we see that in so far as
patrons aren't going to cafes
we're nervous about whether
we'll get patrons coming to the civic
for shows
and so where the promoters will come to
invercargill but actually the key driver
for people to come and do a good job is
just got a bit harder and we're going to
have to be a bit more innovative about
how we
motivate and keep energise the people
that we have when we're dealing with
people who have less respect in this
courtesies
the second question was
the report is more
a note of incidents
rather than a report to this committee
on risks and indicators and trends and
probably what i would expect to see
mr chair we had this discussion at elt
i think it might have been andrew
cameron who said he would have expected
to have seen a report that had something
like the numbers of near misses and lost
time injury and so on and i actually
said i very clearly recall the chair
praising us for the very helpful
narrative that was presented at the last
rna by riskin for health and safety
yes
i think gary actually came to present it
and it was um and look can i say to you
that we're aware of the need for better
data in relation to health and safety in
relation to everything across the
organization
but michael will support me in saying we
can't introduce new systems
across the organisation for everything
at once
and actually we're still
encouraging our people
to report near misses and to really get
the value out of health and safety so
we're working on it uh but we're also
seeing making sure that you get the
headlines
so you've caught me out ross
[Laughter]
because ross i look i agree with you i
mean i rost your points well mate and i
certainly
uh agree with that and and clear i think
we're not wanting to there's no
divergent view i hear your point about
systems
i think it's something that
progressively we will want to see um uh
shall we say picked up in the report
there's clearly
a focus around systems with a view
towards us collectively being officers
and actually that the
obligations and duties we have under the
act are being fulfilled so that's around
systems
it's around risk identification uh and
there are so it's even that there was a
six league of duologists which is even
self-verification that the systems are
working so
um uh i i will be looking i think we'll
be looking for that sort of step and
move as we go on
thanks to ross any other questions by
the way folk on the uh on the the screen
please make certain you uh either raise
your hand or wait you wave your hand or
or whatever to if you've got questions
please
right is there anything else that people
would like to raise about this report
thank you very much i i will um i do
have anybody um what's uh resolution
sorry do i have anybody
thank you darren do i have a
thank you rangi
is any discussion on the motion it's
quite full that we received the report
on the wrong one sorry i've gone back to
item six that's not good that we receive
the health and safety report
no discussion can i um
put the motion then please all those in
favor please say aye
those against
it's carried thank you very much we've
moved to
item 8 which is the
updating on uh working on working
together which is possibly
unhappy back to you jane jane has got uh
family matters to attend here today so
she was a late late apology to us that
she couldn't be with us i know she'd
love to be but uh
family were more important oh michael
you're in front thank you appreciate
that
didn't go to couture councillors um yes
i'm stepping in for
jane uh work with her on this project uh
it is an update as i'm sure you're all
aware the
pgg work stream is uh coming to its
conclusion
with its uh legacy report um
[Music]
that
the draft is in hand
and is slowly working through its
various
editing
phases
you'll notice there is a budget update
there also
um it looks like the project will be
coming in well within budget we are
expecting an increased spend as we come
to the end as you would expect
with um additional work to conclude the
legacy reporting
uh there is one small amendment i
suspect there to the budget is that the
planned uh
councillor development um that was
including the
richard westlake workshop on governance
uh has unfortunately had to be
uh
cancelled at this stage but it's
effectively postponed
uh to a much later date um so that means
that that spend was unlikely to now
be able to happen which thought i would
flag that in terms of that budget
and the only other aspect that we will
need to continue to work on and come up
with a plan is how some of that
monitoring functions
pgg does is transferred to this
committee
post the end of pgg which is expected
around june so other than that i'm happy
to answer any questions thank you very
much uh michael and certainly uh if not
plans to get into the breach with uh
jane knott here uh any questions from uh
members of the committee
no no not oh have we got no no no no no
nobody were you keen to make a comment
sure yeah just another question just a
comment um
in the third paragraph in the purpose
summary thing
part of the report it does reflect on
a view by jane that
this committee should turn its mind
to steps that could take to mitigating
the risk of project gains being
eroded by political statements which
appear to criticize the performance of
the organisation or of staff although
some may not have been that intent
um i've already flagged that as a risk
going forward
um and i have given some my some thought
to my role in that
um and work with them
my role my current role is a compatible
fix or
fit with that um so
i'll give you an update shortly on that
thank you uh nobody appreciate that
any other questions for folk
i think i think um
if i could just um perhaps
i think segue then into some of the
updated risks that the committee or the
the group the pgg looked at
um on pages
26 and 27 you can you can see
the risks around 9 10 and 11
which is
i think i just wanted to call it the
challenge for us all
with the project in a sense winding down
uh jane by the way has done tremendous
work and i do have in my hand a draft
legacy report which includes
uh the wrap-up interviews that you have
all done with me and jane
that is that is well in process
um uh winding down the reality of it is
we've got a number of months prior to
the elections and let alone post the
elections to live
with the good results of that program
and um so that that is an ongoing risk
and one which
i'm not certain there is anything i can
do other than remind us
that actually we have to live with what
we have established over the last couple
of years with jeff and lindsay's help
okay
final chance for any questions or
comments people like to make
oh sorry if we got biggs is somebody
yeah just a final reflection on that uh
page
25 that you referred to
event number five i'm not sure the post
mitigation likelihood of being green is
actually the right color
um i still think in the communication
area we have some
risk in that area
we certainly haven't done well in
selling some of the
issues that we've had around council
museum um going forward it's clearly one
of those
um annual plan goes out at the moment
whether with a suggestion that we employ
a consultant in that area
so i guess internally that's something
we haven't achieved in and green gives a
false impression by my my way thinking
yes frankie yeah well i would i would
completely disagree with that saying
that i believe the communications
are effective
and are doing their job
and they're working within the
environment they have to work with which
is not easy
with various comments coming from
elected members so i think the
communications uh
dealing with everything as best as they
can
thank you rangi
there is a complete package here isn't
it it's actually the behavior within the
chamber and the comments that we make
there are there are the
relationship which inevitably we must
have particularly as we go into the
electoral cycle with the media
um and again i'd come back to the work
that michael and the team have done
around the charter and actually a level
of of the spirit and commitment that's
in behind it i can only perhaps impress
that upon the situation
um
rangi and navi as we go forward
right i wonder if we could move to the
um
uh the resolution for this please um
which is uh
yeah
page
23. sorry was there anybody else sorry
have i cut somebody off
yeah um me again uh bruce
just just as a response to ringy's
comment i mean
and while he might feel that comms do
well
with the information they've been given
and maybe some of the comments that are
made in the painting
if that was the case why do we need to
employ a consultant to and i quote
um craft the narrative for the museum
project
i mean
we've got a team of seven or eight com
in the comms team and we need them to
work and solve
it doesn't sit well with me
sorry i'm just looking looking here
there might be some clarification
officers with with them
browns
i'm sorry i'm not aware that we are
employing a specialist comms
or a comms person to be completely
focused on the museum
communications
it's a different planet
you're on mute so if you're trying to
explain it quite a water chair um
i will find that it's in the
consultation document that's gone out or
some of the supporting documents that
have gone out with the annual plan and i
don't appreciate council are saying that
i'm living on another planet
and a bit of respect would be would be a
suitable sort of thing for that
i think that's a few point uh rangi if
you could be careful please about your
comments
okay you know this is part of us trying
to look by the charter we respect each
other and uh
perhaps suggesting where we live might
not be the best the best way to do that
so
look i think that's a matter of that's a
matter of fact that you can that can be
dealt with out outside of this
possibly the con nature of the
conversation does suggest um
uh while not suggesting that staff
aren't being effective that actually our
approach to communication might have a
different color than green
and we should be aware of that
yes darren
if i can chair
i think part of the issue is that
there's been a lot of opinions expressed
around the museum redevelopment project
uh
and and they've been
debated discussed
uh directions set
the direction that set which is the one
that's communicated
um
doesn't
reflect every opinion that's been
expressed but you know when you you're
focusing on explaining what's happening
uh it's
the communications is looking forward
it's it's not necessarily about
explaining every point that was raised
in in the debate so whether that was the
concern that that councilor clarke had
or not i'm i'm not sure
thanks
thank you
well i would say under we still have to
um complete the annual plan
in which
these things will come to fruition
so
that is when
if we're looking at the details of how
we communicate that's when we move
forward
and dwell down um and into that but at
the moment we have to work with
something
thank you rangi and that's right that
i've seen the consultation document
that's that's out and that's the process
which you know you're in the middle of
now so it's wise to see that going
through it is actually an important
stage consultation when we have to think
seriously as
elected members what is the what is the
communication we have um because
actually you put your best foot forward
you're asking people for their views um
and you have to be careful what you say
and do in that period because it's the
communities period it's not yours you've
heard you go
right there's anything else that people
like to raise about the working on we
can get the report at this stage
your hand is still up uh um
nobby is this something we'd like to say
no that's fine
right okay if we can move to the uh
recommendation do i have a mover and a
seconder for this motion that we
received the report thank you rangi
thank you vex
new discussion on the motion
you've been none i'll put all those in
favor please say aye
those against
it's carried
right we move to item nine please which
is uh development of organizational
risks and peter i think it's a verbal
update thank you
morning mr chair um just a verbal update
on uh where we are at the moment the
finance and assurance teams have
developed the individual risk registers
and they've been reviewed by the general
manager and we've developed the top 10
risks that are for the financial
insurance group that will be reported
later on in this meeting
the remaining groups
customer environment leisure and
recreation infrastructure in the office
and the ce are developing their risk
registers
once they've been reviewed by the
respective gms these are reported
at risk insurance committee meetings
going forward
while we're doing this we're also
identifying risks that should be sitting
at the chief executive or the elt level
once this
register has been developed and
reviewed that will be reported once
again going forward
mr chip thank you what's the what's the
time scale on the the the sense of
development here peter in terms of its
its arc of time when will it be complete
i'm planning on the june meeting to
report the remaining groups top 10 risks
at the june meeting and then
at the the following meeting the elt
and then going forward it'll be
one group at each meeting to
deep dive on any risks that are in there
going forward brilliant
um i take it at some stage we will have
a sense that uh while there are four or
five groups there that we will have a
sense of what is the the
the the council
strategic risks the higher level that
yes that will come yeah those will be
the ones that uh will end up at the elt
chief executive level brilliant
can i invite people to raise questions
as they wish to for a better stage
yes jeff so i'm just interested who
decides what internal
audit might be done
you're talking about the internalizing
contrast to the risks
well and yeah because it says both
internal water and continuous
improvement
that's the next item i'm sorry
sorry jeff
we're dealing with uh just the update on
the organizational risks cool
but i might i might have read that wrong
issue when i introduced you peter sorry
about that if i set you on yeah
okay
um look that's that's that's great uh i
mean it's it is the it is the one key
piece from our agenda
in a sense that's missing that's not a
criticism by the way at all peter but i
just realized the process that you're
going through so
uh we'll be keen to see the fruition or
at least the the end of this first stage
of it coming to us and we get that that
process going so uh thank you for your
report and i'm i'm glad with the
progress and uh we've got a sense of
this this stage will
um meet or join us with the june meeting
which will be superb so thank you
um to look i'll move from the chair that
we received peter's verbal update do i
have a second to please
thank you rangi
or any discussion on the motion
i'll put the motion in please all those
in favor please say aye
all right those against
it's carrie
right that's the suspect you're staying
there peter the internet and continuous
improvement so jeff keep your question
ready i think we're into it uh peter in
your hands
thanks mr chair um
page 36 on your uh agenda i hope it
coordinates that way um table one the
continuous improvement request you'll
note we've completed four that are
shaded out there so they'll not be
reported going forward
and those are internal
recommendations that have come from
staff or by our own internal audits from
our own internal order too
uh table two you'll notice that we've
actually completed a further five of the
deloitte recommendations between
december and now and we've included the
sensitive expenditure review
recommendations in there
and just at uh page 36 i'd just like to
note that
while we've been
conducting this work we haven't
affected councils processes or services
of any way while we've made these
changes to processes and procedures
and also noted in the order in zid
report on the annual plan
annual report was the comments of how
we're progressing on recommendations
from these deloitte reports
brilliant thank you peter
and i appreciate you responding to her
one request from the chair which i think
is is very helpful which i will endorse
which has given us a sense of what in
terms of the outstanding recommendations
what's their their significance so thank
you for that
um
jeff you let's have your question please
peter
sorry uh peter
how's the internal audit
established and
[Music]
and the priority given to it what's the
process
i inherited some of the internal audit
plan for the environmental services and
building services teams for their
accreditations
or food safety in the bca
apart from that working with michael to
develop the internal order plan to have
deloitte conduct those
and we're growing the internal audit
across council at the moment the
internal auditor position is currently
vacant we have uh offer of employment
being agreed on for a
and a new employee starting in late
april
from there we hope to actually expand
the internal audit plan
as i say previously it's been focused in
in two main areas which is where quality
control was previous to the council
reorganization in 2020
so there's a working process so
historically it's not being done
internally it's been done by deloitte's
um i can't answer that um having only
taken up a position 12 months ago um
since i've taken up the position we've
had this internal starting picture
yeah
cool
i think michael might have some updates
as well yeah through yourself chair um
yes um
mr grant the
the internal audit program has developed
over time so and and historically it was
put forward as a program to the risk and
insurance committee where we've now got
a session um with risk insurance where
we bring up the proposed proposed
program to risk insurance which will be
agreed as a
for all in
our core internal
audit program that does not include a
legislative one which peter alluded to
quite rightly which like um
get our accreditation etc and secure
that then we need to ensure those with
our audit process on that side of it but
it does we will report those back
but it does include the ones which are
optional or um any accounts would want
to do as a
sequence here so we do have a rolling
plant that was presented
in august i think it was
um our intention would be to continue
can
continue to update that on an annual
basis so
the committee here is fully aware of
what the program is cool
i think it's a
if i can pick up the tenor of your point
jeff i think it's it is really important
so thank you for reminding us that um it
feels like uh
june or the next meeting we will have a
formal
um
uh report actually on what the program
is uh particularly for the next next
year and
there will be a chance for committee
input which is actually really important
um by the way peter if if we're planning
that it's also useful just to bring the
internal audit charter just to check
that we've still got that up to date and
that it's right so that uh
again if i'm meeting the spirit of your
question jeff we we have formal input um
once a year at least on where that's
going right well
there's any other questions folk would
like to raise with peter over his report
i just wonder i mean i might split this
to michael um the technology one post
implementation recommendations the
accounts payable is a few sitting there
we've had some discussions from you in
the past on on this is you you're
comfortable this isn't here
through yourself chair yes uh
comfortable this is um
we have a plan in place in relation to
resolving these issues um i've got a
verbal update in public exclude which
i'll give a full and frank discussion
about where we're at to in that position
thank you appreciate that
i need to always check the screen
nobody's nobody up there's got questions
right can we uh then look to receive the
report over move her in a second to
please
thank you darren thank you vex
um uh is any discussion on the motion
being none i'll put all those in favor
please say aye all right those against
that's kerry thank you peter appreciate
that man that's very helpful
uh pro dual project minute this this has
been the most awaited for report aaron
the project management office um uh oh
it's not it's gonna be ladies thank you
in your hands
thank you chair
just to
obviously deliver the report to the
committee
um most of our in-flight projects at the
moment are are tracking quite well
uh city streets obviously has some
challenges with the contamination we've
found
but we are working around the opening of
the
farmers building so that's uh
that's a tricky project but working well
uh anderson house is delivering well
stead street is delivering well so our
yeah our inflight projects are um
delivering quite well
looking ahead to our next tranche of
work there's some challenges in the
market obviously there's a
quite a bit of flux in the industry at
the moment
and that's something that we're looking
at at the moment in different types of
procurement uh
strategies and
whether we look at going out for you
know sort of engaging the contractors
early with requests for interest or eois
and looking at different procurement
methods
and to engage the market early
really wanted to open up to any
questions really
thank you absolutely appreciate
appreciate that um uh that's great so
members do we have questions here for
lee in particular and probably aaron as
well
yes frankie
it's more of a comment um regarding
the the current climate
at the moment for procuring
everything involved in in building
industry whatever
um and this
this will not change quickly it's going
to go on for
a couple of years at least for it to you
know write itself and combined with the
probable
impact of finance being more expensive
i think
our timing of our next most critical
project which is a museum
is is well timed where it sits
i would not like to see it any sooner
than it is now
so i think i think we are fortunate
that
um
that timeline is operating like this i
think it's
you know
where the planets align i think we're in
a good space
thank you for that knobby good i see
your hand up oh sorry did somebody out
jeff were you going to
no no it's just actually snobby your
hands upset
yeah just just two things on page 42
of board books um
it seems there that the brand's home
original budget for the bank's home
upgrade was 11.5 million and it is now
sitting at
close to 25.5 million that seems an
awful lot of increase yeah
nearly 14 million dollars
yeah but that's uh well this is the um
the branson pipeline's been broken into
three sections
and that's pipe supply
drill shots and main construction
we've been working through the with the
team on various different cost workshops
as the project's developed obviously
it's increased in cost
and i suppose the testing of that is the
original budget was probably too low to
deliver that scope of work
happy to talk to that
um
some of the committee may recall that in
about september last year we came and
spoke about the brinks home pipeline
project
at that stage we noted the fact that
there was a significant shortfall that
we expected to occur for that project
at the time i flagged that i expected it
to be at around the 20 million mark
but that we had gone back and that we
were fully
re-repricing that project
now that we had more information going
forward we will be bringing a full
report to infrastructure
committee in the coming couple of weeks
to talk through the exact build-up of
that project and to
receive approval for that
amended budget from the committee from
the infrastructure committee
thank you euron so there's more to come
on that that's that's good to know
robbie you had two questions you've made
you've asked your first one i think
you've got a second one we'll stay tuned
secretary to the civic administration
building project again
um
another one that was flagged in the long
term plan about a year ago
at 16 million dollars and now close to
28 million dollars
that's that's a that's a nearly 12
million dollars
that's the 27 is a placeholder so the
team have been working on the historical
information and the project brief and
scope
and we've had another qs review of all
the costs obviously we've increased
contingencies
and other um
costs in regards to the risks in the
market at the moment
obviously when that budget was formed as
well and that budget was conceived we
were in a different market so that is
just a placeholder of what we what we
believe to be the absolute limit of what
we could be facing and we're working on
a value engineering and a scoping
exercise on that before we
proceed any further with that particular
project
just a reflection chair
um
you're okay with that yeah sorry just go
for it nobby yep i know we're in a
different marketplace um
but we've got two projects here that are
very close to going up between the two
and 25 million dollars
that's got to be more than the
marketplace um i heard
a le and say that original project was
cost was too low but i mean that that's
a significant amount right
and there's got to be some impact down
down the line for us on those sorts of
um upscaling of budgets
and the other issue i guess i'd flag
is that i guess there'll be some
some questions in the community and i've
already raised this myself about why we
are investing potentially 28 million
dollars
in a
civic administration building when we
don't know what the future of local
government looks like
well the plan for this report really is
to highlight the maximum cost that we
could we could incur on these projects
so i suppose it's about flagging the the
upper end of risk
how we deliver that project and what
that project looks like in in its um in
its delivery may be something different
so whilst um you're seeing the numbers
you're seeing on this report that is the
upper end of the risk um matrix but what
we do deliver would would be something
different
um so really it's about putting that
information out in front of the
committee really i wonder if i could
invite uh claire to comment i think
she's got some comments to make on this
mr chair it's probably fair that i
comment on the 16 million for the cab
because those councillors who were
around the table at the time will
remember that
actually that was a short piece of work
done
to give a best estimate of cost without
a full condition assessment on the
building to compare the cost of
improvements here
with um investment in a new build
as part of city block
and so what's happened is that between
the time of that work being done in 2018
and this work being done with far
greater knowledge of
the
condition of this building
and as lee has said the total scope as
opposed to value engineering getting to
an agreed project there is a significant
increase and there's work to be done to
get back to a point that everyone is
comfortable with
mr chair i'd also comment that in the
context of the future for local
government it's worth recognising that
invercargill city owns a building which
is
at full earthquake strength nbs
after it's had a minor improvement
already full already full
and that
the future for local government will
definitely require some staff to be
seated somewhere within
the lower half of the south island and
indeed invercargill and i think that i
would make a claim that
you would do the best for your community
to make sure that your cbd has employees
walking around at lunch time by making
certain that it's this building that is
the
only choice
for
the for the seat of local government in
the region and future
yes
yeah i think that's an extremely valid
comment
because it will be right there and right
now it won't be we will we can provide
that it's it's i think claire has made
an
incredibly important comment
uh with the future of local government
and the potential amalgamation
um you know we don't know what's going
to happen
we could need more space
it's a difficult time to be making
decisions about investment so i take i
take your point on that and i also take
the point about being um foresightful in
the way we should do it darren it's
probably also worth recognizing that not
every other council is in the same
position that we are
mr chair could i just advise the council
that as recently as monday
and with a commitment to an ongoing
discussion
officers have engaged with environment
southland who are looking at their
requirements to make sure that we are
aware of each other and seeing if there
is
synergy to work together in part
can i um ask a systems question please
leah and aaron um
and i guess it's a follow-up in some
sense to to navi's situation i don't
know when the ring song
uh estimates were prepared or the scope
was prepared but i do sense it was prior
to the pmo being created is that am i
roughly correct in fact
so it's not that it's not that a pmo
automatically means we have great
estimates which will never have a
variation
[Laughter]
no no but i think you can i think you
can see where i'm going how do i have
you know what is the benefit how do i
have the assurance the pmo
is going to is going to help us bring to
the table right scope right price given
in mind that when you're pricing it's
still speculative about what's in the
future
what what what are you able to bring
that is giving us um
not this won't be repeated but it's
perhaps greater assurance over over
initial estimates and therefore funding
needs etc well we're building a team uh
chair
that's got a lot of capacity and
experience
so and been able to sit down and really
analyze these projects i mean we really
got into the under the bonnet of a lot
of these projects
and work through you know what is risk
what is contingency and we've started to
you know
polish this report and start to bring
figures to the table that are meaningful
they're they're accurate
and they're challengeable and so i think
what the pmo
brings at the moment is clarity
uh some assurance experience and putting
down data in front of you that's
credible in the community in the future
so when the wind wind projects are
mooted
you know we have a brain wave to do x
yeah
what's the asset management asset
management so yes sorry thank you
clinton
i'm going to believe sunday thank you
thank you thank you for that clear when
our asset management planning condition
assessment suggests there's a there's a
uh significant project to be
contemplated commenced you know the idea
of business cases etc there's the pmo
involved at that stage
i'd like to think that we would
definitely be involved in that stage and
i think that's when you know we can
start to develop and use our experience
and the tools we are developing you know
every every week at the moment um to to
bring better clarity of what that scope
is
you know go through good practices you
know going through investment logic maps
going through business cases the sort of
thing we're doing for the museum you
know putting some rigor around a dollar
putting a rigor around a scope and
putting it putting good data in front of
the council
and this approach has integrated through
throughout the council um so i can speak
to that one um at the moment to be
completely honest the pmo is plugging a
little bit of a gap in terms of some of
that business case work and investment
management going forward in terms of
making sure that we get the right
figures put in front of the elected
members
what we do have though out of the
changes that we've made to the structure
of the infrastructure team
is a role that's dedicated to do that in
the lead-up to the next long-term plan
so that we will have that ability to go
actually back to the start of these
projects and formally business case them
better scope them although again not
fully scope them ahead of the long-term
plan we still expect that there'll be
some changes but to get a little bit
better at that
um the other thing i'd note is that with
the brent's home
project in particular there's a couple
of factors that come into that increase
some of it
frankly is a i guess a lack of maturity
within the organization in terms of
pricing those projects early but the
other one was that council also made the
decision to significantly change the
alignment of that pipeline project
and that's also significantly increased
to the cost there was a desire to make
sure that we did not go through queen's
park
uh we've also then resulted in prod the
project being priced on
open trenching where we now are going to
be drill shotting under rivers things
like that so there's some significant
changes to the scope of the project as
well as the fact that we needed to
develop a bit more maturity in terms of
contingency planning what were
professional fees going to be things
like that
it's useful
um
thank you thank you for that um
uh just just a couple of things three
the three waters program i didn't
necessarily understand all the short
comments that were in the box on the
bottom of page 42
so things like panel and contractor
performance was just a statement but i
wasn't certain what that actually meant
is it good or bad oh that's cool so
wrong words i mean what's what what does
that mean it's actually a um carry on
from that uh the line above final
delivery program is subject to resource
coordination with sdc in the
construction panel and the and the okay
sorry got you yes i was reading it too
quickly so our teams our teams are
working with um sdc and just making sure
that you know there's a limited pool of
contractors out there and there's a lot
of work out there
in that same space
are you finding your procurement
procurement strategy has enabled you to
and will allow you to think of these
different ways of procurement we're
being we're we're we're looking to be
very agile at the moment you know we've
we've gone to a
design and build sort of view on a
couple of different projects we're sort
of early phase on that to see how that
other market reacts to that um early
engagement has been good um so yeah so
we're um
we're just keeping ourselves very agile
on that sort of space we're looking at
traditional traditional methods whether
we design it up fully ourselves
um looking at the timing of program and
delivery at the moment we're in a really
really hostile flux uh space and as
council pod just said that's not going
to get any better anytime soon thank you
what i would note though just to add to
that is as much as it is a challenging
time at the moment um i guess we should
also be heartened by the fact that we've
got a number of new entrants coming into
the market in invercargill that i guess
are quite excited by the forward program
of work that we have um and that's led
to some um you know some very good
delivery on some projects and that's
spurring more interest in people
entering the market and setting up an
invercargill which is great
i think over the last three months we've
actually seen a lot a lot more increase
in our in in
interest in our projects as well
good it's good to have the market darren
sorry erin could you just expand when
you say new entrants to the market and
invercargill they're not new to the
sector they're just new
down here that that's exactly right
thank you
sorry uh um jeff i see you've had your
hand up i think uh navi
yeah thank you chad just just one
reflection on on the
comments that the chief executive made
um
you know i struggle a little bit still
with the amount of money we're putting
into the
civic administration building
no doubt that we will lose three waters
to a centralized function possibly
roading as well
certainly when the rma is sorted out
that it's going to be regionalized so
that will go away from us
where we should at the moment but the
chief of zeal is quite right if we end
up with a combined council because i
think that's where we'll go to because
of the drop off of those
those other
three areas of work um
reality was that the uh
the building would have to be in the
city
the issue for me is if we have a
three
councils dropping into one and so 120
rate payers where there's currently only
50 something in
50 000 population in the city
why would this council
fund a building upgrade for a combined
council
why wouldn't we leave it so that all
that rate pays and shouting could
contribute
right
there's perhaps an issue here which i'm
not entirely certain is related to this
committee um i presume somewhere we have
gateways in terms of thinking through
where projects are at and actually their
ongoing relevance is that is that the
case we do and this and this is actually
at this you know the very early ones
we're looking at briefing scope yeah and
that's you know discovery has been the
first phase and that's why we flagged
this number we'll now go through a bit
of a brief and scope and that's you know
engage with with staff
um the only comment allowed is that the
fact that
this building is is needing an upgrade
it's been a long long long time since it
has had you know a lot of systems and
that are
old well past their um sell by date so
as much as i understand you know there's
a lot for the future this building is
in serious need of
um
some modification and upgrade
okay well i think there must be as you
say there's a very initial phase here
that's going through so i presume there
is a gateway where where even the more
print the the higher level policy sort
of type of question strategic questions
of knobby will will be ones that are
actually dealt with at some stage than a
measured process that you've outlined
here
okay there any other questions for lee
or indeed here in this stage
i think it's really useful thank you for
entertaining me with a with those
questions around actually what the pmo
is doing
i noticed by the way not every
project has a has a variation in fact
there's zero and i think you've had
you've got some good results haven't you
if i heard it correctly around the cedar
street flood banks we should acknowledge
those sorts of things are also occurring
and in a much better optic now over our
capital program so lee thank you for
your work saying with you aaron thank
you appreciate the fact this pmo is
is delivering for us which is great
can i move us please to uh the uh
resolution
uh which is that we receive the report
center the questions probably sure i
should move uh positively with my thanks
that we received this report and i have
a second to please
thank you darren any discussion on the
motion
there'd be none i'll put it then please
all those in favor please say aye
those against
it's carrie thank you very much
could we please move then to
the policy program update
is random zoom oh brilliant sorry i
didn't see you there i was wondering
where you were so great welcome to the
meeting and i'd invite you to lead us in
this discussion please
hello councillors um so i'll take their
report as read this is an update on um
progress with um
updating policies and the report at the
last risk and assurance meeting um
really just provided an oversight on the
approach noted that
this year will be a very busy violent
year for bylaws um so we've made a good
start to the year two consultations have
been completed
and deliberations will take place
over the next month or so
um and good progress is being made
against the rest of the plan there is
still a lot of um policies that are due
for review coming due for review now um
and so we are prioritizing obviously
those ones that are of higher regulatory
status and just to make sure that we're
moving through the work in a systematic
way
um those policies which have been
completed since the last meeting are
attached for reference
and i'll be happy to take any question
thank you for that rihannon
this is probably thankless work in the
sense that we are a creature of
considerable
numbers of policies bylaws and positions
we need to state for certainty for our
public it's the way we operate it need
to operate so um
in case we finish this item without
saying thanks thank you this is as i say
possibly appears like a thankless task
but it's nevertheless very very
important
members we've got
uh iranians update we've got a sense
that there is a heavy workload here it's
being pinned to risk
and importance which is makes a lot of
sense and we've got um uh stuff that has
been has been put through which which
again is helpful uh we have any
questions or comments for annan please
oh there are sorry uh knobby and
was the second one to see
i was worshipping me so lobby you first
please and then tim
yeah thank you chair um just one thing
for ianna on page
67 of board books it talks about
proactive release of information
and when i read through this document it
does cover
big chunks of what we would want to have
in it but it seems to miss out on what
happens to stuff that we take into pe
and then subsequently do nothing with it
it just seems to sit there forever and a
day
and whether this policy should cover
some sort of process that as we take
stuff into pg we also decide on when we
openly release it as opposed to somebody
actually requesting it
um
sorry had you not finished
yeah i'm finished yes sorry um so
through your chair yes so the corrective
release policy is um addressing the
issue that you're talking about
counselor so um when
you will receive reports going forward
in public excluded those reports will
indicate the plan for proactive release
of those reports
so that is obviously um
this point not a retrospective process
it is a
process from this point in this policy
is dealing with that
okay thank you
um i think just to clarify nobby's
question
what will point when i take it this
policy is neutral as to whether the
matter is in public or in px
that's my understanding i'm i was
referring to the question around the
public excluded
okay no thank you appreciate that that's
um that's that's fine nobody's fine too
any other questions for
oh sorry sir tim my apologies
well
um i'm alarmed by the implications of
this policy
uh it's i have not but it seems to have
been triggered by the interference of by
emails
by the sea in september last year
the implications for democracy and the
separation of governments in management
are dire
that a whim
council can deny or restrict the use of
access to emails
council can
have
cat black
access
to disclose and intercept
any emails
on the say so of the manager or the ce
and this creates a massive issue for
the privacy of both the public and
myself
effectively means
the ce has
intelligence on any elective members
email communication
the public should not rest happily
knowing
that any message to me can be
intercepted and disclosed
just a point point
a point of order cheer
um i thought uh in committee you're not
allowed to read from script uh that was
my understanding understanding orders
you cannot read from script
uh
bobby i think for the sake of the
conversation right
sorry
my qualities uh rangi i think for the uh
for the um
uh nature of the conversation we're
having i'm comfortable that certain has
read uh his comments um uh and i take
them in the spirit which which they're
given so i'm comfortable at this point
baron i think you've got a point you'd
like to make um a couple chairs firstly
i i think
his worship's use of the term interfere
is incorrect
interfering
hints at
preventing emails from being accessed
and i don't think that was the case
the policy and the the fact that for a
larger organization there is an
overarching
body slash person slash department
responsible for
uh servicing internet access and email
access is not uncommon
and ultimately somebody has to be
responsible
we've had it pointed out to us on a
number of occasions that
all information sent to us
regarding council is subject to lagoyama
requests
and
if there is concern that personal or
private information is being accessed
then you simply don't use your
icc account for it
um if if i had
council business uh oh sorry personal
business i wouldn't be using my icc
email address to to conducted in
but as i say it's not an uncommon
process and particularly the larger the
organization the greater the risk of
um something interfering with it this is
an age where fishing is tremendously
prevalent
where
emails
from other organizations are so
realistically
constructed that it's important to be
able to double check in many cases and
and i'm
comfortable with uh with what's proposed
i also
don't think that looking back to what
happened in last september is
particularly
useful it's about
a policy
moving forward
just to
be
uh for my benefit these have been
adopted we're noting these we're not
we're not being asked to approve them
clearly from their motion correct
that is correct yes so they are actually
they are actually existing policy that
have been completed so we've been asked
uh to note that um leslie i think you
have a point that uh you'd like to make
please
thanks mr chair i was i was just going
to comment really that the electronic
use acceptable um usage policy sorry
electronic access acceptable use policy
policy is is an absolutely standard
policy i've experienced exactly the same
in other major organizations and with
even larger
electronic access abilities
and
there is nothing of any concern in this
policy that we have as you have pointed
out already past it's it's an absolutely
standard and necessary policy
in an organization of this size
thank you ross yeah i'd support both uh
um
these these
um they're both private and public
organizations
doesn't matter the size is becoming
increasingly common it's entirely
appropriate and uh
thank
those that have prepared the paper you
need to have a country view
i don't believe it's appropriate
thank you
do you have any other comments on on
paper
a policy like this is is excellent in
the fact that
it forces members to think before you
write because once you do write or
whatever
it's done so it's it's it's
you know as everyone has said before
it's
it's i think it's essential in running
the uh type of organization especially
when it's a democratic
organization totally essential we're
here working for the public it's public
service
and one would hope that within that
spirit we can approach this policy
rather than rather than seeing us as
something which would prevent us
from communicating um i think that's
that's a key point
write any other views before i move to
the motion
i wonder if i could move to the motion
please which is that we receive the
report
we note the engagement calendar and
policy schedule which rhiannon certainly
addressed in the first part of a
conversation and actually that we note
the motor vehicle policy lingoma in
proactive release policy as well as as
we've just discussed the electronic
access acceptable use policy thank you
darren moves that i have a secondary
thank you rangi i appreciate that is
there any discussion on the motion
i'll put that motion then all those
motions in all those in favor please say
aye
aye those against
it's carried thank you rhiannon
appreciate that as i said a thankless
task potentially so thank you again do
appreciate it
could we move then to what has been
received as a late item
which is the
quarterly report which was verbal but
now has a paper patricia thank you
thank you
now this quarterly report was presented
to ppp back at the start of february i
do believe so this is pretty much
bringing it to this
committee as a noting and to note any
risk items within it
the next quarterly report will be for
the march quarter and that is we're
starting to work through we're in the
final throws of march now um
and from a risk perspective the key
points typically are on capital delivery
and you've already had the report from
lee's pmo report
on that
and the
i've probably have noticed the impact on
co i've covered on the levels of service
that were raised in that report back in
december
um and that will be reflected again i
would suspect in the march one
but i'll take it as read and if there's
any questions
obviously it's a challenge to take it as
read
well um other than
i'm probably saying that for a couple of
members within the room uh i think it
was what i would say can i can i ask
from up from a risk perspective if i
could ask you to put that lens on
um patricia is there any particular
point that you'd want to draw a
committee's attention to
or is it business as usual um the
biggest risk that as i said continues to
be the capital program and delivery of
the capital program though it is noted
that
you know we've got some projects that
are delivering well and others that are
behind but it's getting that right mix
of this is how much we're going to
deliver so we know how much to fund
and we've we have that all nicely
aligned
yeah so you've got both the delivery
issue but you also got in in the real
issue of actually how do we fund this at
the right time yes okay appreciate that
i think we've got to accept that as a as
just the running current risk
um i guess i would want to refer back to
our conversation with the pmo but i make
some assumption now with the pmin
operation
between yourself as true from a treasury
management perspective and the pmo
driving the major projects you've got a
better alignment
yes we're getting there that's so good
it's the answer i wanted to hear bobby i
think you have a question
thank you just two questions really um
i just wanted some clarification i
thought at one stage and it might have
been the first quarterly report we got
in this financial year that our um
investments our cash investments in the
bank were around about the 53 million
mark
and now it's down to 49.7 i just wonder
whether patricia could help us why there
seems to be some drop there um
that i do cover again in the financial
risk report so councillor can i answer
that in that report because then i'll
have that paper right in front of me
okay that's fine and the other issue is
the issue of net debt which
um
as we head into the annual plan that
gets thrown around quite a bit um
and so i just want to be clear that um
in my mind in case i've got this wrong
that net debt is just the debt level
minus the cash or cash investments
correct
correct so if for argument's sake
um
just without being specific on the
figures if we have a million dollars
worth of
we still have to service that there
don't we regardless of what the
uh cash or cash investments are
yes we do
that's fine thank you bobby if i could
just add to that with it hopefully not
complicated that's why when we talk
about prudential limits and we'll come
back to that with the treasury report
we look at both i mean net net debt is
justin is just the vehicle by which any
external party
whether it's our rating agency
in particular would look at us they say
there's your balance sheet you've got
some debt you've got some cash your net
position is what worries me
that there's the external view but
that's why also a range of so so we know
what the prudential limit is on net debt
to revenue but the other part is
obviously also what is our
interest cover
because that's also important because i
think that gets then to the point i
think you're making
which is that even though we might focus
on net we've got to service the gross
debt from an interest cost perspective
friend of mine your your investments are
also bringing interest as well so
you do need to have both you need to
have the balanced view of all of it
thank you for your question nobby is
there any other questions
uh for patricia on her report at the
stage
thank you for that that's helpful even
if we teased out this one to those small
risks and i do appreciate
uh is that darren your committee's
already had already had this paper and
would have given good analysis so i
appreciate the fact that we've had a
chance at a committee just to consider
what are the key matters with it
that's been the case i wonder if we
could move to the motion please which is
that we receive
the uh of where it says verbal what is
called
the update on the quarterly performance
update we don't need to actually put the
variable we can delete that
do i have a mover in a second to please
thank you darren thank you rangi
appreciate that
uh any discussion on the motion
i'll put up all those in favor please
say aye
those against
it's carried
uh by my calculations we're up to the i
was hoping i got to the end of the page
was at the end of the open session but
i'm still gone
uh delivery of the the annual plan
um
kiara again
so um
i will just um speak
briefly to the process
of the annual plan and then patricia
will
raise any points that she wants to
highlight around the financials
um so this report just details the
schedule for delivery for the annual
plan as well as the key risks i'll note
at this point that we are on schedule
and consultation commences today and
will close on the 29th
of april
um the
time at which the annual plan will be
adopted will is flexible and depending
on um
primary risk which is identified in the
report which is obviously managing the
team's availability through coved but
there is plenty of time there's three
weeks flex in the schedule if there is
um significant sickness within the
finance and trilogy and policy teams
so at this point um
there is no reason to believe that the
annual plan will not be finalized on
schedule
um
the other point that i'll just draw your
attention to in terms of the risk
management is just to note the
conversation earlier around the delivery
of the king consultation messages around
the museum so to clarify that the
consultant that's been engaged worked on
the consultation document and that was
as a result of having no senior
communications advisor on staff at
presently as well as the high workload
on the other
projects and engagements that have
previously been discussed at this
meeting
um
so
i will hand to patricia and then happy
to take any questions
thank you thank you patricia
so from our risks and assumptions which
is the key critical
things for this committee within the
annual plan
um
i do want to note that we wrote this
paper before the councillors
changed the um from the staff
recommendation to on the museum so that
the percentages in the paper are at 7.77
not 7.78 which the consultation went out
on but um
the key assumptions have been around and
where we were considering change has
been around inflation
um in a long term plan we had 2.9
as our inflation figure
um berl came out slightly lower
um the market and cpi would indicate
that it should be higher we've left it
at 2.9 at the stage um but we have made
allowances on
on specific cost items
to increase those a bit more
um in terms of some of our benchmarks
and kpis which we've set the balance
budget has been um retained met the
balanced budget benchmark
but it's the maximum it's the rates
affordability which is the
those measures which we are currently
breaching on the draft annual plan
because they were set as with
effectively a 7.5 maximum rates increase
or our other 1-1 affordability was plus
a margin on local government cost index
which we would also breach
that
was the those key ones we have changed
the assumption on capital delivery from
the ltp as well and retained it to the
same as the current year at 70 rather
than 75 for funding purposes at this
stage so i didn't quite hear that
patricia so from a capital delivery
program we last for the current year it
said it's 70 of the planned budget it
was supposed to increase to 75
for next year but we've lowered that in
the annual plan to 70.
so we'll keep it at that same level
and that was
those were the key points that i wanted
to raise there thank you and uh that's
uh both from you and random very very
helpful thank you for that uh members i
wanted to stage there uh there are
questions i stress i appreciate that
you're doing work uh elsewhere through
the actual annual plan but for us this
is about risks
the relevance particularly around the
the assumptions is that it comes back to
us when it gets to the annual report
time
um amongst other things and also there's
obviously funding risks associated with
what costs we ultimately have as you've
already indicated through capital um so
i'm interested in particularly around
the risks associated with either
getting the annual plan out and we've
got the assurance
uh or not the assurance sorry wrong word
we've got the indication at the moment
we're tracking okay and we've got these
the risks around the assumptions that
you've given us there any questions that
people would like to raise with either
an or patricia
yes frankie
um i guess it's
my my questions comments around the
consultation process which is underway
now
council
unanimously adopted the annual plan
for consultation and i'm worried about
potential
contamination of this process
by
elected members comments public comments
during the process and the effect it
would have
um on the feedback the public may may
give because obviously we are seeking
uh feedback on the document for the
information provided in that document
we've all agreed on that
so i'm just wondering the risk that that
that poses to conducting
the consultation
with
respect to all the requirements in the
act
any other member
yes so through your chair um
so when we worked on the long-term plan
we worked with councillors at that point
around um the communications approach
and really the same approach stands for
the annual plan
of course councillors may have different
views on different points but we are
consulting on this consultation document
that has been adopted
and
it's important during the consultation
process that the public has the
opportunity to share their views and um
it's helpful if all councilors work
together for that end
um
chief executive may have also something
she wishes to add
so my other comment said there isn't a
annual plan b is there no
sorry
uh knobby i think you've got a point to
make
thank you chair um yes well that
i'm sure that uh councilor pledges uh
um comments are directed to me so i'll
respond to that
um
yes i do have some different views from
what's in young plan especially around
the museum
and ongoing progress to the museum
i
will have a voice that can't be silenced
but i've also had
external advice and advice from michael
morris that says to me if i go down that
track of
promoting
what i think is the future for the
museum
or and if i make a submission
to the annual plan i can't then be part
of the ongoing
governance review or vote on the issue
and i'm fully aware that uh
that
significance for me so i'll take some
advice on that
and but i am well aware i can't have a
foot in both camps
oh look thank you for that uh not
because actually you're quite right you
can't you can't be a submitter in the
decision maker on the same event same
event so i take it you're intimating
that there is a decision you make you're
reaching over this matter so
um i i would want to
in that case leave leave the matter
there uh rangi i think you've heard
comments from lobby which uh
um you will take on board and also just
remind us of the charter rhiannon is
quite right and i think i said before
this is the public's time
which yes you i would argue strongly
it's great to encourage people to
participate and submit but you see it's
their voice you're wanting to hear
because
as i understand it unanimously you put
your best foot forward
this is what we want to do what do you
think
that's the critical part in terms of
this consultation period and mr chair if
i could add to that if counsellors are
wanting to give messages that encourage
the cut the community the public to
participate
then the best message would be that we
encourage your participation and we ask
for you
to indicate what activities
you think we should cut back
as much as what activities you support
i think rhiannon and indeed every as an
officer and and everyone that sits
around the table people can come and
tell us what they want to see you do or
what how they want you to keep the rates
down
but actually giving you some clues over
what they see as lower value would be
really helpful
yes there's always both sides
dollars down means service down
generally so it's wise to have that in
mind yes michael
through yourself chair um it would be
remiss me not to highlight um the
funding of depreciation that's in the
rest this is a riskin
committee and and
i think it's prudent to highlight that
um this the percentage that's set there
um is in line with our ltp so i would
like to highlight that and we're able to
do that under the standards to keep that
alignment uh until we've got um comfort
in relation to any revaluation the
depreciation at 100 is on the full
revalued amount as we went through our
annual report
we haven't validated that revaluation
we're doing that at the moment once
that's finalized that will take effect
in the next annual plan perspective
there may or may not be a catch-up in
years ahead
it's a it's a fair warning i mean it's a
fair bit that depreciation will rise
significantly given as you say the
debates we had at the end of last year
over what a reveal the sc base would
look like you're strung out um
i'd just like to bring this committee's
to this committee's attention um
the risk of predetermination and the
reason i'm raising it is that on
tuesdays
hearings for
speed review we had a submitter who
basically at the start of her submission
uh said
i don't know why i'm doing this because
you always make your mind up beforehand
and i'm worried about the public
perception of our processes
um
and that we do not
we do not portray open minds the way we
debate things
and we don't get you know
we have a build up to things and the
annual plan has its time to come when
the cards can finally come on the table
but
i can see how people get
this feeling that we just we've decided
things way before and i just wondered is
that a risk um that that we can identify
and try and work on
you know that's part of working on
working together i i don't want to sort
of shoehorn everything into one little
program but that's actually in lots of
ways what it's about how do we build
trust and confidence
in the community
um
i've reflectively erased that comment
with me uh rangi before um and i
appreciated that and i don't know
whether that's that person's view about
invercargill city or whether it's it it
is particularly a sector-wide view
uh what's called consultation fatigue
uh and also a view that actually i can
say well you know i will tell you what i
think but i don't actually believe you
the public sector governors whether
that's in the cargo city or wherever
uh um are really you know you've already
made your mind up
so the question is how do we how do we
eat an invicargo
portray authenticity
and it's a combination it's a that's
good all working on working together i
hate to say that
but it's also it's also in being very
clear
how can your submission influence us
let them know
they still proof is in the eating isn't
it when you get to consider those when
you get to a how you listen to the
submissions
and actually how you treat them in it
but i'm giving you a lecture on local
government 101. so darren i think your
hand was up and then i think i've got um
molly
thanks chair um it's a
it's a tough balance and and i think
it's worth reminding councillors that we
have also made the same assumption
about consultative processes that that
we've submitted on
um
so it's it's an easy space to to sit in
but all that sits with us and i think it
comes back to as chair said the the
working on working together process is
that we should always look for the
opportunity to try and maintain the
higher moral ground um i suspect that
the the topic was raised after the the
deputy mayor made comments after tuesday
night's extraordinary ppp
um and
and there as a journalist i see the
double-edged sword of
you've got a person who was has
expressed an opinion through the process
that we got to at that point and that's
fine that's absolutely where we're
supposed to to do it
um but when a person with prominence
makes a statement to the media the first
thing i'm going to do as a reporter is
report it
and
and i agree that it
from a general perception
uh perspective some people might see
that as as confusing but
i mean if councillor clark accepts that
having made those those statements that
essentially rules them out of the
consultative process
uh and that they that he's going to come
forward and make a submission which of
course is his prerogative that's that's
fine but probably needed to be clear on
that when making the statements
thank you
nobby
thank you chair um just a couple of
reflections there um i fully agree with
darren
and as i've already alluded the
i am very aware of the personal
prominence
role that i have and i will resolve that
shortly
um
on the issue of um
predetermination
taking a stand is not predetermination
by my view it's just saying that you are
not in a majority view
and i am quite aware of the process
i've never tagged anyone
a member of this uh this council tend to
like talk to
outcomes or projects
um
tend to be outcome focused not uh input
focus
um
and i just
reflect again on on what the chief
executive said about if people are
coming forward they should tell us where
to make the cuts
and i reflect on the comments recently
by councillor arnold in a meeting where
he asked exactly the same thing he said
if the outcome of the annual plan is
that we
as a council only accept a four percent
rate increase as opposed to 7.7
uh percent
um
do you have a plan b and the chief
executive said well actually you'll have
to tell me where you want to make the
cuts and she she made reflection on
center plots opening hours of the pool
on the library
and whether we have uh the reception
area open the coming hours that we have
it open all the current days the week we
have though
and again that's um i didn't think that
was a hell of a positive sort of
approach um i would have thought that if
we made the statement that we're only
going to give
four percent
or approve four percent then
as a collaborative excise counselors
would sit with
senior management and work out how we
got to where we needed to be within the
four percent because it's not about
cutting services
i mean i there are lots of ways i've
already raised four or five different
ways that you can you can get to that
end result on four percent so it's a bit
of motive to be saying look we're not
going to be planting gardens down the
center of the streets and so
that's not helpful in the process for me
but i am fully aware of the issues that
brandy's raised and darren race and i'll
certainly do my best to resolve those
thank you i can i just um check with
count with councillors here we're
discussing
risks around the annual plan and we're
almost now practicing how we will debate
it going forward
and and and i think there are two things
that have come out of the conversation
which has been very helpful
and nobody we need to give him time he's
indicated a potential position he will
take
i'd encourage you to make that
reasonably quick in the in the
circumstances nobby but i respect i
respect that but
by the end of the day i'm almost i think
we're almost practicing what we might be
saying when it comes to the time of
thing of deliberation
what we have established is the
importance of us through this period
in terms of
keeping the process for the ratepayer
and for us to listen
because we have put our best foot
forward in that proposed annual plan
we need to be letting them heavy say ask
the questions
encourage them to do that darren and
leslie and light are there to see any
comments uh you have had your hands up
tonight you're fine at least there's
anything you'd like to say uh just very
quickly mr chair pretty much to um
what you have just said i was going to
make the comment that
i wanted to bring
the matter back because i think it had
strayed to the fundamental process of
democracy that we are talking about um
it had strayed a long way from that into
personal opinions and personal decisions
but the fact is we have a fundamental
process of democracy here we have put
out and started a consultation on a
document
that we did debate some of the finer
points of during council and some of us
expressed different views but we came to
a collective decision on a democratic
consultation process
we are obliged as councillors to
approach that process with an open mind
as part of fundamental democracy and
that's what i wanted to bring us back to
thank you thank you leslie i appreciate
your point final comment ranging no it's
just getting back to my very first
question and my i don't think i've had
the answer yet and that was the risk of
contamination to the process which would
make our annual plan
plan process fail because of the
contamination of misinformation or
different information as opposed to the
document that we've put out that's the
risk i'm raising
does that come the end of the day
and it gets someone
says no you've that was a complete fast
judicial review
is there i mean that's the risk i'm i'm
looking at
i think i think the fact that we've
discussed it at some length rangi
is an acknowledgment that it is a risk
the mitigation
is actually going back to leslie's point
in part in the principles what phase are
we in
and actually to recognize and i repeat
myself we're in a phase where we we
are
asking the rate pay or the community so
i should be better the communities of
invercargill to submit
that's what we should be encouraging
rather than rather than proffering our
views
which is counselor
um uh looks like bobby
is navi as knobby is hunting
um he has to think seriously about
predetermination which doesn't help the
trust and confidence unless you take a
particular position and he's thinking
that one through
so i think we have answered it yes it's
a risk the point you've raised yeah we
do have the mitigation that's in our
hands
and we have a charter we we've done the
whole working and working together so we
should be able to not that one through
together would be my argument
any other comments that folks like to
make at the stage i think we've thrashed
this reasonably well
random thank you and patricia thank you
can we move to the motion please
uh which is that the uh the committee
received the report on delivery of the
22-23
annual plan i'll move that from the
chair do i have a second to please
thank you rangi i appreciate that
any discussion on the motion
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye aye those against it's
carried thank you
um i would like us to we probably are
duel we we break um but i would like us
to
uh try and deal uh with item 15
please uh at this stage before we make
that break because it will be in time
for us i think to probably try and track
down
our auditor i've been talking with the
audit oh okay well done thank you be
jumping on shortly but could we could we
deal with item 15 please and i propose
we'll take a short break um
because yes we want to be finished by 11
30. thank you
um
so
this report is
it's got a number of different financial
risks within it and i want to just work
through each
one very quickly for you and give you
the highlights in each area in relation
to the treasury report this is the
report as at the 31 of the 31st of
december a lot of water gone under the
bridge since then um but it does
especially in relation to inflation and
ocr
so that does give the commentary at that
point in time it's now very different
commentary
um
debt
was 87 million at 31 december and we had
50 million in cash
that had gave us a net debt balance of
38 million
since january we have been using those
cash reserves so we had a number of turn
deposits coming due they have started to
be used
um you'll also see in the treasury
report there's a minor breach being
forecast in our fixed rate hedging in
years two to four
this breach is forecast on the basis
that a debt level will rise to 150
million
um
should it not get that high because of
changes to capital program that breach
will not occur but we'll keep monitoring
it it'll depend on what that we do take
out within the share we do need to go to
our jfa and borrow so
if it's fixed it will just move that
slightly
in relation to a debt the levels
continue to reduce both for rates and
non-rates debt
um
but note the rates numbers and the paper
do not include any unpaid amounts for
the current year so the 21 22 financial
year
just also to note we do have nine
properties where we are at summary
judgment proceedings to recover rates
um and they've been filed in the
district court and the abandoned land
sale that was referenced in the report
that didn't actually get to sale the
owner was identified and the rates were
settled prior to the sale
and we've also included within this
report sensitive expenditure and that's
the listing for the first six months of
the year
and
and then we've also got the insurance
program which we are starting the um to
progress the
renewals
on all the various pieces so the first
renewal will be our infrastructure
and we're already starting to work with
the broker and the insurer on that
there are any questions i know i've
covered it very quickly
yes and michael i think it's got a
comment you'd like to make as well too
please thank you michael
yes thank you through yourself cheer i'd
just like to give some clarity in
relation to the um treasury state which
might
give him give some further clarity to
how
the cash and the debt is managed from
that perspective
under our um
you will see on page
113 of board books
the credit rating of double a plus
one of the key aspects for maintaining a
double a plus is
retaining a certain level of cash in the
bank in relation to be able to pay your
bills as they fooled you
and that is taken into account when
they're doing the credit rating
the level that we have had in the past
has been a significant significant level
in relation to what our minimum
requirement is
and that has been due to our
term deposits falling due
we're now in a position that as they
come come on stream we're able to
actually realize those we can lower our
cash position to that minimum position
that we're we're able to do that we're
working very closely with our assessors
to make sure that we don't lower our
credit rating of double a plus but it is
in our in our interest obviously to
minimize our borrowing as much as
possible
to keep the interest and the charge to
the right power down so that's when you
take away
what you're applying the funding to and
look at just the funding from a treasury
perspective we do manage treasury on
that basis and we try to have the
minimum impact we can to the ratepayers
in the lowest cost student so i just
want to clarify that because it brings
some clarity to that position but for us
it's around managing the risk to the
ratepay
and the risk in relation to that double
a plus and the risk of us having a
heightened um interest
charge but we have had some legacy
deposits that we've had to work through
to get our treasury position back on
track
that's very helpful uh insight and and
reflects um the importance of of
uh knobby i think you raised the
question i think patricia you did answer
that um the the the
the importance of our net debt position
and the importance of both cash holdings
as well as also our gross debt
um so i take one of the one michael and
that's very helpful
do you have any other questions folk
would like to raise it's a it's an
omnibus um nobby i think i see your hand
up
just one quick question for patricia she
said
some of those maturing cash investments
have now fallen due and the cash will be
used can you clarify where that
that used is are we just holding it for
something or have we actually used it um
we would have actually had to go and
borrow money um the different projects
including the fur um
as different things have fallen due um
stead street
you know city block
um city streets those normal capital you
know million dollars a month invoices
coming in
we have to pay them
so that's where it's been used
thank you
yes darren
thanks chad look just a minor query
under sensitive expenditure um
we have an item
on page 130 of board books where
the mayors sought reimbursement for a
car hire at lg z conference so i'm
pretty sure that council had directed it
was
preferring to
make taxi chits available because the
mayor didn't have a driver's license
can somebody help me with this one um
yes uh mr chair councillor ludlow is
correct
uh there was a decision that a rental
car would not be funded a rental car had
been requested to be organized before
that decision was made is my
understanding
and um the invoice has been presented to
the mayor and payment sort
thank you
any other
observations questions people like to
raise it is a it's actually a really
important report and i feel like we're
probably it's going it's getting a bit
too quickly but in the sake for the sake
of the meeting it's it's great to see
this yes
um
referring to net debt and uh it's
critical that you can forecast where
you're going to be with your net debt
if you forecast your revenue
and
which would obviously offset your net
debt and you start
playing around with your revenue and
deciding you
don't need that
then where
the risk of net debt
then i mean they both go hand in hand
you can't have one without the other
so i'm just looking
at um
at the risk of of tampering with
forecasted revenue
um interfering you know that that there
is a risk that this net debt will
become uncontrollable if you if you
interfere with your revenue
michael you want to make comment on that
i mean i could make a comment but i
think it's important that we we hear it
from the people that are managing the
city finances yeah
through yourself chair um
i'll tackle this one but i might i might
defer over to patricia
shortly
most of our revenue is is
pretty
steady in relation to the fact it's
linked to rates income from that
perspective we do have variability in
our revenue so there are subsidies in
relation to capital program
expenditure and that's lumpy expenditure
as well
that does cause us challenges um and
you will have seen in some of our
previous reports around trying to secure
that funding from
particular debtors and that funding
being difficult to come come on board
that that causes challenges for us and
we have to borrow for that in the short
term until such time as we can um get
the cash flow in
so
most of our our revenue is fairly stable
from that perspective but yes we do have
some pretty significant fluctuations in
relation to the capital program to
manage so it is a bit of a headache from
that perspective but i guess i was
relying on your say forecasted rates you
you need you plan those for a reason
correct and then the the potential risk
of not having those and then the the net
death
then becoming
i think i can anticipate
you you have to adopt a treasury
position relative to what is in your
current proposed annual plan if you
change the revenue line your treasury
position has to change as well right um
and you have to think what that means
and again that's where the other thing
that comes into that is actually you're
going to cut services you may get away
with it
because everything's in sync but if
you're going to maintain the services
drop revenue
you're going to have to think about how
do you where's the funding gap coming
from so it is going to affect your
treasury position as well they do they
are all related
thanks for that
um just to follow up from that question
because i think i might know um where
the question was heading um if you
if you borrow for um any operational
costs from that perspective
which i wouldn't recommend at all
you have the impact of you
you're not got the guaranteed revenue
coming through you are there for
borrowing you therefore have an interest
associated to that borrowing you are
shifting not only
the cost of
the shortfall of the revenue to future
rate payers but you're also shifting the
interest that you have to
incur in relation to borrowing for that
that gap in revenue so um
hopefully that's yeah no no just the way
the way they're all linked yes yeah
any other questions like to raise we've
got quite a fulsome um
resolution to work through here so uh
which is good are there any other
comments we would like to make is snobby
and then sit in
two two quick questions for michael um
if our net debt
dropped two million dollars
would that change the double a plus
rating
um through yourself cheer if the net did
dropped um no but um
it would need to be some external things
meaning increased
meaning
yeah
increases
uh moved by two million dollars it's
currently i think i'm
patricia said 38.
if it moved to 40
um
would that you're saying that wouldn't
change the double a plus rating we'd
need to work through our external
provider counselor uh from that
perspective
off the cuff i would say no but i would
need to check with our external advisor
yeah that's fine i'm not trying to treat
you
could i just jump in there there's one
other questions one of other point there
and that is is the ready agencies aren't
unaware of the quality of that debt
sure so they will do analysis why would
you go to 40
and what are you spending it on it's
just your question that you asked
patricia before they will want to know
why
as much as what is the outright metric
yeah
so
putting aside the issue that michael
discussed about
borrowing for operational needs which
i'd never agreed to
i think that would be madness i agree
with that
but wouldn't expenditure cost
cut
that doesn't affect net debt though does
it
so if we cut our expenditure in the next
12 months
that doesn't impact net debt
um through yourself chair um all
expenditure effects net net debt is how
we fund everything
from that perspective it's either
borrowing or cash so um
it all affects it
including sale of assets from that
perspective because the cash from that
impacts on it
i wasn't suggesting any of those things
i wasn't suggesting borrowing using cash
investments
or sale of assets but if for argument's
sake we have 30 million dollars going
into uh infrastructure renewals and we
dropped that by 2 million
that wouldn't affect net debt would it
it wouldn't require any borrowing it
wouldn't require any stuff being laid
off
what if i could jump in here please
because i'm just we were conscious of
our time and our agenda here now because
i think again we're getting fully into
the trap of
i think a very important discussion
uh michael that would need to be
considered when you uh consider feedback
on your consultation period and you're
trying to look at you're at adopting an
annual plan
and i think the question's very good i
don't have any trouble with the question
robbie i'm just perhaps it's the timing
of it uh and michael i'd like to suggest
that you and patricia think
um through those sorts of questions
because they're very good questions but
they're ones which would be useful for
the councillors to have in mind
when they come to adopt
the annual plan
and so there's a couple of meetings i
suspect to go before you get there so i
if i could suggest that be the case
that would be released i hope that's
okay nobody because i you know i hear
the point you're trying to play which is
how do we pull and play on these levers
and what is the impact and it's a very
important question for us to to master
but i sense dealing with them directly
on the floor here isn't advancing our
discussion at this point in time is that
okay nobby
yeah that's fine i guess i guess i'm
just wanting to
um from a ratepayer perspective to make
sure that we've considered all those
levers before we go to the increased
rating yes fair point
so tim you had a point sir
yes thank you
mr chair the
uh
it seems when you're discussing
20 million here and see anybody in there
it seems pity to
raise an issue with a
fire cut
but
it's often small things like that that
the public can understand
um
and mural cards and all that
um
[Music]
and
so i think
just council should
adopt the policy of when you're going to
send an invoice to
the mayor
you um
have this
discreet discussion with them because it
was so long ago it was at blenheim
and
[Music]
you can't just
it was only 48 hours before
the paperwork
the
um invoices dragon raged on us
thank you sir tim i hear your objection
i think there is an important point here
in terms of the receiving of this report
which is that our sense is to look at
its reasonableness it's one of the
things we're doing it's called sensitive
expenditure
i think in this situation our hands
particularly are
tied i don't mean that in a in a
hand-wringing sense pun intended um two
decisions that have been made by council
and if the view was taxi is appropriate
and not a rental car
i can see there is a matter of a
personal uh difference of opinion dare i
say debt dispute
and i think that's something that would
need to be taken up
with
uh in in appropriate courses clearly
there is a debt that's outstanding
um and and i think that would be the
appropriate course it's not that it
couldn't come back to this committee but
i think at the stage we need to
recognize we do have an item here that's
outside what has been considered by the
council as reasonable
and and we're noting that uh and i think
the level of whether whether there is a
debt and dispute that's a different
issue which may or may not come back to
this committee at some stage in the
future
right is there anything else people
would like to raise at this point
um i've just i've just had a some
perhaps clear you might want to suggest
what you're saying here is that actually
we didn't want to lose sight of
navi's very good questions and in fact i
think some of the
the broader issues around it i'm i'm
wondering you're suggesting that perhaps
i let this paper lie on the table or we
adjourn this for a different day mr
chairman senses that it would be useful
for all counsellors to really understand
what counselor clark is driving at to
understand the management responses to
those and whether there is some room in
there
and i think that you're cheering of that
discussion is actually very helpful
thank you and whether it is um
uh adjourning this particular item
uh to a further discussion or whether it
is closing this
particular item but then agreeing that
there would be an alternative time i
don't think it needs to be
uh if i say in person i mean a zoom yes
time would be something it works
anything workshop yeah yes um i'm
conscious that counselor clark would
like it to be public okay that's fine
and i don't
have any difficulty with it no not at
all
so that was
the thought behind it
so perhaps we can consider as we look at
the motions then if you if there is a
strong view as you've suggested uh it
could be
clear that there'd be let's call it a
public workshop um where we look at some
of the the funding levers that we have
in its relationship with revenue and
expenditure
um
preparatory to the discussion that we
may that you will have around the annual
plan that that may be useful yes darren
um
i think for a matter of clarity it would
be an extraordinary meeting
we just need to distinguish between
the fact that workshops are not public
they can be public are they
they could be public equally mr chair if
you adjourn this particular item then
you'd have a paper that you would be
basing the discussion from
and i think that's not unhelpful either
i think it's a point of clarity to i
have no problem with the issue being
discussed in public in fact i think it
should be but i would probably defer to
your greater experience here there if
you want us to
if you were happy we would adjourn six
of one and half a dozen of the other as
long as we have the discussion yeah and
it's open that's a good thing and i
would it would be one that that even
though it might be um sponsored by this
committee i would be keen that all
members of the council be invited to if
they wish to come yes
um can i just propose through the chair
that
the report's separated from um
because it sounds like we want to do an
education piece around
the treasury and funding of council
by to the committee and and
some insight to the public
we can look at how we can do that and
achieve that but i'm not sure it relates
to the the risks that are before you in
relation to the report that uh the
current risks in relation to treasury so
maybe we bring it to ppp
it's more like the uh it's more like the
the the um the continuation of the
annual plan paper we've had
what you're making
yes swangy so does this anyway touch on
levels of service
and the degradation to achieve that to
use those as levers
degradation's interesting interesting
word um uh
i i think i think the the point is
um uh claire has suggested is there um
uh is there a desire um and i think
michael's used the word an education
piece an understanding piece
which has clearly come out of the
discussion and sponsored by particularly
nobby's um very very good questions
um uh is there is there a desire for
that to be held
well now the reason i asked about the
levels of services we're getting quite
complex
and yes into that and and obviously any
changes significant changes would then
need to be consulted on so yes creating
this feedback loop
so it's not it's not i don't think the
id we're talking about a public workshop
okay and and it would be about
understanding the levers and the choices
that you will have when you come yeah
consider the annual plan it's not a
deliberative workshop well can't be
deliberative i suppose but it's not
deliberative in the nature that you are
directly debating the annual plan i
think we've got to be careful about that
but this isn't understanding that this
is understanding the decision correct
but obviously when you talk about levels
of services the work involved for staff
to prepare
the potential
options it was mind-boggling you know
this is not about preparing options for
the no no no no but the scale of what
levers you've got yeah because how can
you use a lever if you don't know is it
a weep hole or is it a big yeah i mean
that's the thing and i i think the work
involved is would be
would be quite massive
well there's a number of scenarios that
could play out
okay because i think primarily what i've
heard is it's around the levers that
relate to funding
and financing
okay as in contrast levels of service so
we can run it on the basis that the
levels of service
are fixed so the question is what is our
what is that what is the flexibility
around the levers we have on the funding
and financing
it isn't that hard to also think well if
we did change those levels of service
how would that have an impact
it's going to be speculative and
hypothetical but it's to aid
understanding
so that when you're dealing with the
real stuff in terms of the annual plan
there's a level of having pre-equipped
ourselves
leslie i think you've got a point thank
you claire and then navi
thank you mr chair you actually just
made my point and i don't see any
any reason that we would adjourn from
moving
what's already
on gender yeah but you've just made my
point about about the
level at which the workshop or
extraordinary meeting if we decide
that's what it will be um would take
place so thank you yes i'm stretching my
my time objectives aren't obviously so
thank you um uh nobby i think you had
final say
yes thank you um
i know i don't come from an end of
looking at outcomes which is really
service delivery it's more about the
inputs that drive the outcome that's the
real issue and for those you don't need
to consult
so
as an example
we currently have and sorry trudy for
raising this but we have a couple of
vacancies in our comms team now it might
be that one of the leaders we look
forward to without cutting services is
just to to
manage more carefully vacancies for able
to say
so that's another lever that can be
available to management to reduce costs
it doesn't mean you take out the comms
function it just means you don't have so
many people here rather than getting
into a technical discussion here point
sustained knobby i need to be agreed
that there needs to be a paper on the
levers rather than getting into the
nitty-gritty of them so look i'd like us
to move to the resolution and look and
i'm going to move it but i'm going to
add an additional point please which is
consistent hopefully with your
suggestion here busy that we move on uh
which is that is that um and i'll put
this way that as chair of the risk
committee i work with
management
to arrange
an appropriate educational
session related to essentially funding
and financing policies or more
particularly our levers and our
understanding
okay and we'll do that as as soon as
possible and aligned with actually the
work you're going to do around the
annual plan so
melanovica sorry that's a rather garbled
recommendation but we could add that to
the end i would appreciate that
so if we just go back malavika to oh no
you need to type that i'll just go back
to the top
it's very clear you're trying to unique
that you're okay so firstly because it's
important to go through this firstly um
we we received the report thank you
patricia it's a very very good report
it's it's the sort of stuff that we
should be getting and it's great that we
are
since the preparation of the treasury
port the cpi for the quarter has
been released the reserve bank has
announced an increase in the ocr while
increases in both were expected to the
steep increase in cpi was not fully
reflected in the interest rate so there
is a level to which we're recognizing
the information we received as time
bound 31 december we had 87 million
dollars of debt outstanding 50 million
dollars in cash
um uh uh resulting in net net balance of
38.
do you want to make that actually add
by the way i think the motion looks a
bit odd when you take 50 off 87 and come
to and you come to 30 my maths is
correct 37
37 37 okay thank you
um there's a minor breach recorded in
the treasury report uh in in the fixed
rate hedging percentage and that was an
important point to note there is a
breach
where council has slightly
uh less than the minimum 25 required in
fixed rate hedges
um and
this breach is based on the debt level
increase in 150 million as a result of
huge capital expenditure the breach will
not occur if that level doesn't increase
to the forecast level it's not
recommended to take forward cover
uh at i think you should say at this
stage
but to continue to monitor debt levels
that's a really important point we have
set a treasury management policy
looking forward to years we are arguably
in breach
but actually
in the current conditions we are
accepting that we monitor rather than
seek to address that breach now
the current interest rates are still
within the long-term plan assumptions
which is useful outstanding debt of all
types continues to reduce that's the
leaders report the insurance program for
the council-owned assets is about to
commence for 22-23 and updates will be
provided as that progresses and that
will be appreciated and i think malavika
that gets me then to the additional
amendment that i am praising the chair
work with management
on an educational session on funding and
financing policies as they relate
to
the impact on the annual plan
that's the additional amendment if we
could have that in there thank you
claire for that
efficient wording rather than mine i'll
move that from the chair um for the sake
of the main door second to please
thank you rangi assuming the debate on
on those heavy sweet but good sweet
emotions
they've been done i'll put the motion
all those in favor please say aye
those against
it's carrie thank you very much
right we need a break you folk have been
going well but i just want to have a
very quick look at the agenda with you
please because um
i have been trying to work reasonably
hard
for 11 30 seconds
ah the auditor's here already g'day
derek how are you um so
by my account we are up to
dealing with what is now automating the
annual report 2022
so i'd like to suggest
given the work that we
take a short break five minutes max so
we'll be back just after
um i guess 23 minutes to 2 11
that would be good i have to intimate
that i do suspect jeff you will be
leaving our meeting early
as we've already sustained an apology
i'll do my best to get towards 11 30
mate look at your eyes going down but
i'll
do
i do think that actually it's going to
take a wee bit longer so
derek if you'll be with us and and and
tai ho for five minutes that would be
greatly appreciated to those on the
board we'll catch everybody in five
minutes thank you
yes we will be probably going a wee bit
past 11 30. so
my apologies my apologies to
schiff you've got to go at
11 30.
you'll be right
you've got to go as well and and graeme
i appreciate you're a wee bit earlier
than that so thank you all in advance
for being here it's appreciated
and i need to be gone as well chair uh
what time have you got to go uh knobby
eleven thirty i have another zoom
meeting right okay so it does really
matter
[Music]
sorry not decorum but cool
11 30 knobby's going at 11 30.
isn't here
ross will be here
[Music]
that was just risk mitigation
thank you that's green code at the
moment so we're okay here thanks ringing
right can we can we uh thank you
for the morning
uh let's just pick up what i
think and i better check but i'm pretty
certain it's the last item which is now
the new item 18 which is the update on
the annual report uh derek are you there
derek oh you are there welcome to the
meeting um
he's been a busy man he was with
ashburton district yesterday when i was
talking to him so i know that he's
getting around the place so thank you
for joining us derek
um i think we're probably in your hands
patricia for this item um before i then
invite uh derek to speak to us to the
late island
um thanks mr chair so this is sort of
couched as a work program for the annual
report and um i could have put it as an
external reporting program but i thought
the annual report is much a better title
for it
um we do
this is being an election year we the
team will be producing another set of
accounts which will go into the
pre-election report for um it will be
released by the end of july
so um
[Music]
[Music]
um and then we've got the annual report
so
then so as you'll know the um audit plan
was delivered last night and we've added
that into your board books
and i'll let dear expect that but what
um staff are proposing we know what the
key
at this point we've identified the key
issues being the revaluation of assets
so a continuation of last year's main
issue we do need to implement a new
accounting standard only one the paper
indicates two it's just been noted
that's been deferred another year for
implementation but we will look at that
one as well
but with the election and when i wrote
the paper we were still hopeful that we
would have an audit that would be
started at the time of the election
it's unlikely to be that at the moment
so what we are proposing that a draft
annual report
full document will be presented to this
council
before the break before it's dissolved
so that you can actually
review it
and send some recommendations to the new
council that will make it easier for
them to adopt it
so the number of representations if you
recall that management and council are
required to make to the auditors could
be very difficult for a new council
so this is our risk mitigation
to allow a better an easier adoption to
actually
provide a full document to you um and
then
with some recommendations that would go
forward so still subject to audit
because i'm sure as derek will say they
still have
some issues with
resourcing
that will continue in this year
and then
you'll have that as a review
point review it and then audit will come
in when they do
and once it's audited we will then give
it to the council for adoption
thank you for that patricia um so
uh i appreciate that point derek there's
any matters that you'd like to raise
uh thank you for your report obviously
we haven't really had a chance to digest
it um
but salient points you want to draw out
for us at the stage please derek
yes thank you
yes granted is still a very
draft report we still need to have
some further discussions with management
to ensure that we've captured all the
risks and issues
that we need to consider this year
but at high level i think
the issues are very similar to last year
with the big one being
the revaluation for this year i think a
lot of focus will be
will be spent on that
and again maybe just to
to note that you know seeing that it is
such a big
exercise and we'll
a big portion of our audit will focus on
that
i think from
management's perspective they need to
start that process early
and also maybe incorporate a peer review
as part of that process to ensure that
what then ultimately is presented to
audit
is at the expected level addresses all
the
expectations and assumptions
as one would expect
so
um currently that is one of the main
risks
i also think i mean in the prior we
picked up a lot of uh prior period
errors
within the financial statements and
seeing
there's also a new accounting standard
coming in this year is is free from
errors
so just making sure that there's an
appropriate quality review process
around the financial statements itself
um
the point that patricia made around
time frames uh agree with that yes
we will still be utilizing the full
extent of the legislative window that
has been provided this year when the
office of the auditor general approached
parliament last year for the extension
to deadlines
parliament
acknowledged the shortage and extended
that time frame for two years
so this is the second year of that
extension
and uh we are still in a capacity
building process
whereby uh immigration new zealand have
allowed for 200 auditors
a special visa
so we are trying to recruit as best we
can
utilizing all levers to to
resource
and build our capacity
um but while we do that we will still
need to utilize the full extent of the
administrative window which means for
local authorities
is the 51st of december
so
the timing for this year's audit
might be very similar to last year
though i think
at this stage we have planned it to be
a bit earlier
but again with um
the current omicron numbers we are
already seeing a ripple effect in terms
of people being off sick and that have
will have a knock on impact
uh probably late on in the year
thank you for that derek that's um
that's again helpful um to get a sense
on what the year will look like members
i'm sure you have some questions for
either patricia or derek
um i do have a number but i would be
very keen to hear yours first
yes darren thank you chair um
i guess given the
the workload that audit new zealand
faces and the staff shortages that it's
had
um uh the reasons why the government's
extended that that time frame and that's
that's understandable and acceptable
i i guess i need to understand that the
perspective
that will go into each
annual report
is
relevant to the time period that it's
reporting on otherwise it will become
unhelpful i know there's an issue that
we've dealt with through this and i
think hope it's it's it's been resolved
but we can't continue to go through this
if windows are extended into the future
yes we'll be good to get out of the
cycle won't it darren thank you any
other comments or questions for people
roddy i just wonder if i could just ask
a few please um derek if that's okay
yes
my presumption is by the way in terms of
this process you can see what we're
doing we want to
approve
a draft
in the way that you said
um patricia by our september i think
it's a september meeting we have it is
september meeting
[Music]
we would like to also consider
a probable letter of representation at
that stage
so that we can make effective
recommendations to
the incoming council
so that's important but can i just
understand one thing
when will you undertake field work at
the moment
so the field work is more or less
scheduled the same time as as last year
i think as i said i think probably
uh the whole timeframe has shifted
based on current resourcing two weeks
earlier than than last year
um
so the representations i think that
patricia is talking about that those are
internal representations
uh the one council representing to the
other council it's a unaudited draft
set of accounts that will be presented
to the committee again that's my
understanding
because
there won't be any representations that
you will be making to us at that point
in time
because we don't know
whether there's any misstatements
or any items that we need to
specifically highlight within the
representation letter
but based on the draft set of accounts
the one council will be representing to
the other council that everything
contained in that draft set of accounts
from their understanding and
knowing the internal control environment
they believe it's a fair and
accurate representation
of the
state of affairs
then it would be easy to keep track of
any adjustments to the accounts and that
can then be included in
um or that can be kept track of as the
order progresses
sorry i want to detail here what date is
two weeks earlier than last year it's
the beginning of early november
so you're starting the final order in
the early no
late october early november
is there an interim can we get it yes
start june
for four days
right okay
okay okay
um look that's fine we we have to be
where we are i i'm struggling at the
lateness of that
um it it is highly risky
um but uh derek i'm guessing i'm going
your hands when you say what your
resourcing is
um that that meant we should be planning
for a december sign off
so that's the risk
um can i just check that ichl and its
audit i'm not asking for the details of
it but i presume
this is all aligned and will will be in
alignment with the audit of the group
yes so so all the subsidiaries
is aligned
and again i think that that's
um impacting on the
icc timeline is to ensure that the subs
have ordered the accounts by the time we
we complete icc's audits
thank you and um michael
obviously we were well aware that the
key issue was going to be the
revaluation of our our asset base is
there anything that your patricia can
say or give assurance to the committee
on in terms of process and that that is
in hand so we have started the process
of the revaluations we're still very
much in the early stages but it's pretty
much about getting your data together so
we can revalue it we're also talking
with our colleagues around the country
who are also facing many of them our
cycle having to revalue all their assets
so that we have some sense of what
everyone else has seen
um look i
had the uh and i did appreciate derek
columbus day the advantage of a
discussion with derek yesterday about
their approach to um revaluations this
year
and as i understand it it actually also
includes use of specialists on their
part
in terms of reviewing our work
so i would be very keen derek
that there'd be close discussion
between patricia michael and yourself
on what actually are the expectations
and i think it would be important that
we have it crystal clear from you
what are your expectations now
if the audit is going to be in november
we can't learn then
what are the expectations
we need to have a level of live reaction
in terms of the
the matters as we go through and i'm
going to put some pressure on you
so i need that
otherwise this order is going backwards
and i don't think it will fret will
reflect well on anybody but particularly
the auditors
okay um
thank you for that i see any other
questions folk would like to raise at
this point
right um i would like to make a proposal
of a change to the
resolutions please i'm sorry for the
latest on swan malavika but given the
situation
i think it warrants it um so firstly
that we received the annual report uh
work program i do notice that small
piece of work you've got to do around
the prefix i shouldn't i shouldn't uh
not acknowledge there's some hard yards
here that i know that you and
claire will be going through
um
uh that we request the officers continue
to work a lot of new zealand
on the other implications of the work
program achieving
sign-off deadlines and that's
particularly in my view around the ppe
the big risk issues that we've got
provide the committee with a more
detailed plan at the next meeting
and update the committee on critical
judgments assumptions and decisions that
affect the upcoming
meetings
i would like to have a specific
additional resolution
that the committee delegates to the
chair of the committee and its
independent member
authority to
work with management to
finalize
and receive
the audit plan for 22
21-22
i think there is obviously and i'm
grateful that we have a draft here from
um
uh uh
derek but we do need to finalize it
and i think there is a need for a level
of
discussion to make certain it's in the
right area
given some of the risks that we have
heard today
exist around the sword at yes ross can
you also add and any discussion with our
auditors as deemed necessary
so management i'm comfortable with it
i'm comfortable with that
so essentially the intention of that is
that actually rather than waiting to the
next meeting to receive and approve
we get we get some go forward on us now
and and i'm asking you to delegate that
role to me and ross
with obviously management if i can be
honest obviously
um so um the chair sorry that the
committee delegates
authority to the chair and independent
member yeah
oh you've got it there thank you
appreciate that um and then obviously
there is uh um the fourth recommendation
that the chair and i write to audit new
zealand advice and the council's
intention
uh around uh approving the draft
unaudited annual report to provide
assurance
to the new council to adopt the annual
report i think perhaps derek my
disappointment around the timing was i
would have hoped that we might have had
some sense of audit results not final
clearly at the time we do that but it
seems clear that we won't we'll be doing
that entirely without the benefit of
significant audit audit insight
that's perhaps my disappointment if i
can be blunt
okay those are the those are the i think
those are the recommendations i'll move
that from the chat i have a second to
please
thank you rangi is there any discussion
on the
motion
being none i'll put it all those in
favor please say aye
those against it's carrie
thank you uh urgent business i don't
haven't been warned of any um
so if we could then move to the
resolution to exclude the public please
i'll move that thank you do i have a
secondary thank you ross
uh is any discussion on that i'll put
the motion then please all those in
favor please say oh
michael
oh thank you sorry i understand i need
to include you jeff uh and lindsay um
that you should you should be uh able to
remain as well as also the auditors
uh um for the benefit of the discussion
on our on our item around last year's
management report
so uh sorry ross
will i mean it that way i said no rangy
you moved it sorry yeah and who's
seconded
you did ross thank you
all those involved please say aye
those against
it's kerry thank you very much